Oh
there are people who talk about the
creative process with such humility you
know there's a sense that something
larger than yourself
has worked its way through to paraphrase
Khalil Gibran's notion about children
the creative process creativity comes
through you but not from though it is
with you it belongs not to me right now
this notion that we are the frontal
lobes of the universe so when I craft
you when we vocalize when we utter
inspiration what are we actually doing
are we creating something that isn't
there or are we merely transcribing
right the notion of inspiration means
we're breathing
and exhaling what we've taken in so
we're nearly transcribing the
observation of what is we're reporting
we are all Kozma Psychonauts and the
creative process is merely what we
brought back as reporters of the
numinous when we go to Plato's realm of
ideals we are as navigated we are as
Dorothy going to Oz seeing the world
through a different lens seeing reality
through a different operating system a
different set of filters and thus being
able to read it differently to see
something that others can't and then
bring that back and then share that book
I think that that's what's happening
during creativity but that's why we
should be humble about respect the gods
there's poetry in every moment
you